- [Lecturer] So I'm Marzyeh Ghassemi
and I'm a professor at MIT.
I'm also an affiliate
of the Vector Institute
and University of Toronto.
And today I'm going to talk to you about
The Pulse of Ethical
Machine Learning in Health.
And I should warn you,
I had a talk that is a tight hour.
I had it all, I've given it 50 times
and this is a brand new talk.
So you are either blessed or
cursed with being the first
people to hear this
particular set of slides.
So my group at MIT is the
Healthy Machine Learning Lab
and we try to create actionable
insights in human health.
And here's a case study
of what you might do
if you're working in
machine learning and health.
So let's say that you
have a patient who comes
into the hospital, Sumana's
having trouble breathing,
she goes to the emergency
room, they do a chest x-ray,
but the doctor can't look at
the chest x-ray for two hours
because there are lots of
people in the emergency room.
But if she's healthy, she would
really like to just go home.
Can we build a model to triage her?
Well, if we wanted to focus on this,
there is a pipeline that we
work with in machine learning
generally where we select
a problem, identify data,
collect an outcome, label,
develop an algorithm,
and then finally look
at post appointment
considerations for our model.
And we've already done
the first one, right?
We know we want to
develop this triage system
for chest x-rays.
And so let's try to do
the rest of these steps.
We're going to take the three
largest chest x-ray data sets
that's over 700,000 images
of chest x-rays as our data.
We're going to create
a finding of no finding
for our label, right?
So that means if there's a
bunch of different things
that you could have diagnosed
from the chest x-ray,
and I want to predict if you're
healthy and you can go home,
the label I should use is no finding.
I'm going to train a DenseNet,
which is a kind of
convolutional neural network.
That's the algorithm
I'm going to optimize.
And then once I'm done,
I'm going to look at
my performance, right?
And so we find in this paper
that we're able to create
state-of-the-art performance
on this specific task.
This is great.
We've gone through this
development pipeline,
but it's not just us who have gone
through this development pipeline.
This paper is a few years old now,
but it was identifying that
there are now a range of tasks
that AI can do at or above humans
across different spans
of human tasks, right?
So anything from tasks that
are done on very young to
very old people,
we now have AI that performs
really, really well.
And so we've achieved
that sort of check mark
of it has very high performance.
What if we got through all of these steps.
like I just told you
with the model we have,
and now we want to consider deploying it
in the same emergency room?
Well that's okay too.
So in the U.S. we have the
FDA and there's different
regulatory bodies in Canada and in Europe.
And what happens is
these regulatory agencies
essentially look at your model
and they audit it the way
that you would do for a drug, for example,
looking at its performance
in different settings
and then they clear it to be released.
This is a website that
tracks every AI system
that's been released by the
FDA, approved by the FDA.
And so you can see that
there are hundreds of these
across different kinds of settings
that have already been
approved for deployment.
So now the question is, let's
go back to my case study.
So she's having trouble breathing.
She has this chest x-ray
and they offer her,
"You can wait two hours for
a chest x-ray to be reviewed
by clinician or we could have
AI triage you right now."
So the question is, what
should Sumana choose?
What would you choose?
So hands up if you would
choose to be triaged
by the AI right now, no waiting time.
Okay, some people.
Hands up if you would choose
the doctor for two hours.
More people, skeptical crowd.
(laughing)
Wow, is this a summer school for AI?
I'm in the wrong room.
So maybe a reason you wouldn't
choose the AI is you've
had a bad experience in the
medical system recently.
So I live in Massachusetts.
There was a paper that came out
in the "New England Journal"
this past month actually,
looking at the admissions
that have happened at 11
Massachusetts hospitals.
They found that at least
one adverse event occurred
in over 20% of admissions
due to the provider's error.
So a doctor, a clinical
staff member made a mistake.
Of those more than 20% were
judged to be preventable
and over 30% had a severity
level of serious or higher
that's just in one state
with some random samples
and looking over this past year.
But what that means is the federal agency
in the United States,
ARHQ that's responsible
for looking at these kinds of mistakes
and their impact on Americans estimates
that there are 7.4 million
U.S. emergency department patients
that are misdiagnosed and 2.6 million
that suffer an adverse event as a result.
And so the question is
that's the data we're
using to train this model,
where else would we get it from?
How well do we think this model
will perform on a patient like Sumana?
Do we think it makes similar mistakes
on all kinds of people?
And you might say there
are other sources of data
that we could use that
would maybe supplement this
so that we don't make serious mistakes.
For example, we have
randomized controlled trials,
but randomized control trials
are actually very rare.
I don't know if you knew this,
but very few treatments are based on them
because they're expensive
and they're hard to do.
One of the reasons they're hard to do is
because you have to create a population
where you can only study the effect
of a specific intervention on an outcome.
And that means that your
recruited population
is necessarily extremely narrow.
And so my favorite statistic
is 94% of asthmatics
would've been ineligible
for the treatment RCT
that was used to design their treatment.
Even worse, what'll
happen sometimes is there
will be a medical reversal.
So top journals in medicine
like "Lancet", "JAMA",
"New England Journal",
we'll publish a paper saying the thing
that we thought was good medical practice.
Actually that's bad and we
should not do that anymore.
What if instead we look at this
from the provider's
practice point of view.
So what happens when you
actually go to the doctor?
If there's not a randomized control trial
on your specific condition
and specific drugs,
they probably are going
to look at what has worked
for other people like
you in the past, right?
So doctors will think,
"I know that patients
have generally reacted
to this medication well."
So what would happen if we took a dataset
of 250 million patients and
then looked at the treatments
they got, just the
medications and then tried
to identify how many patients
followed a completely
unique treatment pathway.
That means they have zero nearest
neighbors in this dataset.
For common conditions
like diabetes, depression,
and hypertension.
For diabetes, it's 10%,
for depression it's 11%,
and almost a quarter of
hypertensive patients.
If you ask the question,
what treatment should
you get next according
to your nearest neighbor?
The answer would be, I don't know.
Because there are zero nearest neighbors
in this data set of 250 million people.
In order to move forward
with AI in health,
we need to think really carefully
about how these kinds of factors are going
to affect the model that we create.
So let's go back and look at this model
that we trained, that
we were very proud of,
that we have a paper in "Nature Medicine"
about just like all those other papers.
Let's look at the false
positive rate of this model,
false positives, because if
you falsely positively predict
that somebody is healthy,
that's underdiagnosis.
And let's compare that in
different subpopulations
because if you falsely positively say
that more women are healthy
when they're actually sick,
that would lead to underdiagnosis
in female patients for example.
And when we run this audit
on our state-of-the-art model
that you know looks great on average
and could be cleared by the FDA,
we find that it has the
largest underdiagnosis rate
in female patients, young
patients, black patients,
and patients on public insurance.
And your underperformance
is actually worse in
intersectional identity.
So that means if you're a black
or Hispanic female patient
in the United States who have
a higher underdiagnosis rate
than white female patients and
than your aggregated group of
just female patients.
This is not just true
in imaging data, right?
So I used to have to,
when I was talking about this paper, say,
"Oh, there are these things
called contextual language models."
And I don't have to do that anymore.
All I have to do is
say, "You all have heard
of language models, right?"
So if we do clinical note completion,
which is a task that actually Epic,
which is a big EHR provider
in the United States
and Canada now has in
many hospital systems,
they've integrated the GPT4
add-on in some hospitals
where if you're typing a note in Epic,
you can use the GPT4 plugin to complete
a patient's note.
Super helpful, right?
Taking notes takes a long time.
So if I start this sentence
from a real patient's note
from a Boston area hospital
with Caucasian or white patient
became belligerent and violent,
SciBERT completes this note
with "They were sent to hospital".
If I started with African,
African-American or black
patient became belligerent
and violent SciBert completes this
with "They were sent to prison."
So this is not just a bias
that's found in imaging data
and it's not a bias
that is easily removed,
it's something that is very deeply seeded
because guess what?
Humans are biased.
And so the way that we provide
care is sometimes explicitly
and implicitly biased.
And that shows up in the
data that we are using, okay?
So this is not something
that we can do, you know,
simply it's an ongoing process
that's going to require
diverse data and teams.
I'm going to go through
some parts of this pipeline,
not all of them because
that would take too long.
And the first one I want
to talk about is data.
And I want to talk about data specifically
in those two modalities,
notes and imaging because
you might be wondering, okay,
there are these biases, how bad can it be?
This is a real note where I've redacted
the patient's self-reported race.
Can you tell the race of this patient?
Probably not because we tested doctors.
Let me tell you, I have a bunch of friends
from when I was a graduate student
that are all doctors and they all hate me
because I test them all the time
and they always fail my tests,
which they're not used to because
they're very good doctors,
but doctors cannot tell,
I promise you, whether
this patient self-reports
their race as black or white.
Well why should they?
Well models can and models
can in some cases because
they're using things that
maybe would consider fair.
They're using statistical
biases, not societal biases.
So for example, in the Northeast,
African-American patients have
a higher rate of hypertension
and a higher rate of using dialysis.
Okay, that's fine.
But it's not just things like that.
So we looked at two cohorts
in Boston and New York
and both very simple and
higher capacity models
that are able to predict
your self-reported race
with very, very high performance.
And sometimes they're using things
that we probably don't want
them to be able to use.
Like if you call a patient
or their family difficult,
that patient is probably black, not white.
If you mention anything
about the skin presented
illness of a patient,
they are probably white.
And that's because dermatology textbooks
actually have almost
no examples of the skin
related presentation of
illness at all on darker skin.
So doctors don't know how to diagnose it,
they don't know how to notice it,
they don't know how to use it at all.
So they just don't talk about your skin
if you have darker skin.
What about in images?
We can all imagine how our
implicit or explicit biases
might show up in a medical
note, right, as we're typing.
But this is a medical image, right?
It's a chest x-ray.
Surely there's nothing here.
And so also I have a
bunch of radiologists,
friends who all hate me now.
Radiologists cannot
tell from a chest x-ray
whether your self-reported race,
not your genetic ancestry as
one weird eugenics reviewer
suggested, your self-reported
race is black or white.
But machine learning models can,
they can do so with very,
very high performance.
They can do so on multiple sites,
they can do so even when we have
evenly distributed data sets.
So we looked at Emory
University where they have
an even distribution of
black and white patients
and they can do so across
a variety of modalities.
And if I ask the radiologist, okay,
give me a list of every
single spurious correlation
or proxy or cheating, you know,
way that you think a neural network
could be sort of guessing at
somebody's self-reported race.
And I'll test it.
It's not any of the ones we tested.
It's not body mass index, breast density,
bone density, or disease distribution,
which was the one I thought it would be.
In fact, you can filter these
images if you're an EE person,
you can ban cast filter to these images
until they do not look
like chest x-rays anymore.
But even things that
have a little more than,
you know what we perceive
as spectral noise
have extremely high performance.
And so this is not information
that you can easily remove
from somebody's medical record.
If you were looking at somebody's notes,
if you were looking at their
medical images and you thought,
"Oh well I've removed any
mentions of self-reported race
from their EHR,
and so my model won't be able
to do the bias performance
that you showed."
It's very deeply proxied
in medical datas in way
that we cannot detect.
And so it's important if you
decide to work with health data
that you recognize, both that
data is a very powerful good,
it's something that we need to curate.
It's something that we need to
have available as researchers
because if we don't have diverse
data sets for research use,
what will happen is what's
happening right now.
Namely hospitals will
sell data to companies,
companies will create
models like I showed you,
they will be biased and
we in academic spaces
will not have the capacity to audit them
because we don't have access
to the same data sets.
And right now that is what's happening.
So health really lags other
machine learning subfields
and reproducibility as it stands.
And it's largely because
people do not release
their de-identified data
under data usage agreement.
There are some data sets
that the community uses,
but it's really lacking in
terms of what other communities
have been able to do.
All right, that's the first section,
that's what happens with data.
What about outcome definition?
Surely there's nothing
sketchy going on here.
Any questions before I move on?
So the question was do we
know what was happening
with the imaging data?
Is that correct?
There is no way to prove it,
but some of our initial guesses are
that it's spectral
information from bounce back
from x-rays when you
have more melanin, right?
Waves actually interact with melanin.
And so it's possible that that's it.
We can't prove that, we don't
have photos of people's skin.
We're assuming that there's correlation
between these things.
(audience member mumbling)
I think it's the differential performance
that's bias, right?
So I think there's no
problem in a perfect society
with a machine learning
model being able to detect
your self-reported race, who cares, right?
The fact that a model
could perfectly detect it
and then it could have some bias judgment
that is made as a result of it
because it's learning from other data
that we treat black patients this way,
we treat white patients
this way, that's the issue.
It's not a problem independently
that you could infer this.
I would say. Yes?
So what we looked at is whether
within a specific subgroup
there was a higher or lower
level of false positives
within the labels.
So you're right that we are looking
at the ultimate diagnosis in
the medical records themselves
as the true label and as
we'll go into in this section,
maybe there are some reasons
to be skeptical about that,
but unfortunately that's
a lot of what we have
to rely on right now unless...
Some of the dataset that
we used in that study,
they're not just looking
at the underlying label.
So I think checks for certainly,
but also the NIH dataset
had independent radiologists
review the charts post
hoc and they had to concur
on the diagnosis in order to
have the label in the dataset.
And so all of the labels
that we use in general
in machine learning have a
specific issue I'll go through.
But you're right that in
health there's an even further
issue that you could have two radiologists
that each have a decade of training
from the best institution
and they could look at the
same record and disagree
about the diagnosis.
That's fundamental uncertainty
that we can't address.
So for outcome definition,
getting into some of these
questions that we've been asked,
this is how you might
create an outcome label
for a specific task.
So my kids' school has a meal policy,
this is true by the way.
They have a meal policy
that prohibits high sugar content meals.
So if you bring a meal to school,
it can't have high sugar content.
So let's say that they want to build
a machine learning model that is helpful
where you can take a picture of your meal
and it'll classify like,
is this meal prohibited
under the school policy?
So how would we build this model?
We would take images like this one
of a breakfast I would enjoy eating
because I think it's cocoa
puffs and whipped cream.
And we would ask a bunch of labelers,
does this have high sugar content?
Yes or no?
And then we would train
a machine learning model
to predict the majority class, right?
If most people say this
has high sugar content,
then we should predict it
has high sugar content.
That's sort of a standard way
that we do this in all
machine learning tasks.
But the problem is this is
actually a little bit different
than the task we're applying it to.
We're not just trying to
detect high sugar content.
Usually when we collect labels like this,
we're applying it not
to a descriptive setting
like describe this image,
we're applying it to a normative setting.
Like if this is true, make a
social decision based on it.
So what would've happened
if we would've asked people instead,
does this meal violate
a school meal policy
that prohibits high sugar content?
And you might all be saying
those are exactly the same.
One is the if condition one
is the then condition, right?
So it's going to be
approximately the same thing.
But if you ask people the if condition,
17 out of 20 say this
is a high sugar meal,
but only two out of 20 say that
it violates a school policy
that prohibits high sugar meals.
And this is not just true
in this meal policy example,
it's true across a number of settings
where you might collect data descriptively
and then apply it normatively.
So for example, a dress
code for an office,
a meal policy for a school,
a pet code for a building
or forum guidelines
about toxic comments, right?
And so in each of these
settings we did the same thing.
We collected data about
specific images or text samples,
both in a normative
and then a descriptive,
first descriptive then normative setting,
on different samples of people.
And then we looked at what
would happen if we trained
machine learning models as we often do
with a descriptive data
and applied it to the normative setting
and compared that to
what would've happened
if you would've trained
the machine learning model
on labels collected from
the normative setting
in the first place.
And what we find is that
models train the way
that we train them by default right now
in machine learning
tend to be much harsher
in their judgments than if
we would have trained them
on the data that simulates
the normative setting
we were applying them to.
So when we collect data
about is this high sugar
and then apply it to,
does it violate the
policy of no high sugar?
We have much harsher judgements
than if we would've
told people the setting
that we were applying it to.
And you can compare the
difference, the impact, the gap,
this error to what would've
happened if you had
very high, I would say
rates of label noise,
high rates of data sub sampling
or just used a much worse model.
So if you would've used
a better model, SciBERT,
in contrast to the ALBERT model
in the toxic comment classification case,
the impact is a 1% difference.
If you use the right data,
the normatively collected
data in the normative setting,
the impact is 6.5%.
So this is a very important problem.
Another thing that we do,
once we've collected data
and outcomes, is try to
optimize our algorithms in ways
that are going to increase
overall performance.
Before I go into some of the
algorithm development work,
any questions on outcome definition?
Alright, great, so how
do we optimize models
for health settings?
Well, what we could do is
what happens right now,
a lot of the time,
which is we have a very
large data set maybe
that's held privately by a
hospital or a health provider
and they won't release their data.
Their data probably has some asymmetry.
So the dataset I'm thinking
of is the VA dataset
in the United States.
It has more male patients
than female patients.
And they'll train some sort
of upstream embedding model,
some sort of representation.
They're not going to release the data,
so they just release the
representation, right?
So they have this latent embedding space.
Now you private hospitals separately
can take your own, maybe more balanced,
perfectly fair data, and
train a downstream classifier
after you project to our
beautiful embedding space
that we've trained and released for you.
So we found that the bias in data
that causes these sort of
upstream asymmetric embeddings
actually gets propagated
forward into downstream tasks
even when you rebalance the training data
for the downstream task
to be perfectly fair.
So this is a big problem that we deal
with looking at the
difference between issues
with the representation that is learned
versus the classifier that
could be trained on top of that
with potentially different or better data.
Motivated by this, one of the
things we've been looking at
is how do we use group
attributes and prediction?
So there's a big question
right now in the United States
in general in the medical
community about how
and when we should use
group attributes like sex,
age, and self-reported race
and clinical risk scores.
So you can imagine the problem
is if we use group attributes,
it can result in worse
subgroup performance
even though it's improving
the overall group performance.
So in this example, if we train
a logistic regression model
to predict sleep apnea with sex and age,
it's worse for younger male
and older female patients.
And so they might have
preferred for example,
the less demographically
personalized model
because it's helping
most people but not them.
And the reason that this
happens in general is
because we either have
model misspecification
where models are unable to capture
necessary interaction
effects between a feature
and a group attribute.
Or during model selection,
when we're doing
hyperparameter optimization,
often what we're doing is
optimizing for overall performance
and that can result in worse performance
for a very specific subgroup.
So what should we do in these cases?
Our argument in this new paper
appearing next week at ICML
is that we should really just audit
and resolve issues of fair
use of demographic data
as we are doing case specific
usage in clinical risk scores.
So for example here, if I
wanted to predict a model,
if I wanted to create a
model to predict mortality
for acute kidney injury patients,
what I would do first
is look at what happens
when I have a group blind classifier, H0,
look at the performance across groups,
compare that to a decoupled per group,
sort of more personalized classifier,
and then compare that to what happens
when I use race as an
input predictor in addition
to other demographic features.
And here we find that this
leads to worse performance
in the model across all
metrics for black men.
And so we would not recommend
that this is used in this
specific clinical risk score.
This is one example.
We show many examples in the paper
where this is not true, right?
So it depends specifically
on the data you have
and the outcome you're trying to predict.
No one solution resolves
all fair use violations.
And so this is something you
have to run on a case basis.
Another thing that might be important
if you don't want to develop
a clinical risk score
specifically because you
don't want sort of these
more regression focused
tasks is a clinical checklist
or decision list.
This is very, very popular in medicine
because checklists are easy
to use, easy to deploy,
and easy to verify.
Unfortunately these checklists
are created by humans,
by a consensus of humans.
And often what happens is you
spend lots and lots of time
having experts come together
and try to define these checklists
and then later a great
paper, like the one below,
hidden in plain sight
will be written that says,
you know, "All these checklists we have,
they actually don't work very well
for specific subgroups of people."
And so one of the things
that we worked on is actually learning
an optimally predictive checklist directly
from data using mixed integer programming.
The nice thing about this is
you get to have constraints
like a specific number
of items for example,
but you can also include
fairness restrictions.
Why is that important?
Let's look at a case study.
So let's say you want to predict mortality
after a specific treatment in the ICU,
continuous renal replacement therapy.
It's an end of life treatment,
it's painful and expensive,
you don't want to give it if somebody
will die right after it, okay?
But we also want to ensure fairness
across intersectional patient groups
because just like my first example,
if you falsely positively predict
that one subgroup will always
die after this treatment,
it will lead to them not getting care
that would actually benefit them, okay?
So when we train the first model
with no fairness restrictions,
we tested this on our ICU colleagues,
they said "That looks great".
It's not using any positive proxies.
For example, one proxy that doctors know
about in medical data is
biological sex at birth.
So female patients have lower height,
lower weight on average they said,
"Oh, it's not using height and weight.
So it's probably not biased
against those patients."
There are some lab tests like EGFR
that have different ranges
for patients of different
self-reported race.
It's not using any of those.
So this should be a fair model, right?
Even though we didn't put any
fairness constraints in it.
But this checklist actually
has a max false positive
rate gap of over 50%
between white men and black women.
So you would not have
wanted to deploy this model.
Where's the proxy?
I don't actually know and
neither do the doctors.
And so it's important to
always check your models
even if they look completely fine, right?
When we add in fairness constraints,
we lose some overall performance,
but we gain back fairness
within a range that is more
tolerable for a deployed ICU environment.
The final thing I want to talk
about is shifts in algorithm development.
So shifts are a big, and
robustness to shifts are a big
issue in the machine learning
community in general.
But they're particularly
important in health
because many of the
distributionally robust optimization
methods that are very wonderful,
perform extremely well
in other data settings,
really fail in health tasks.
And further, if you try to
use stable learning algorithms
like differential privacy as
part of your optimization,
what we found is that
differential privacy by defaults,
if anybody works in it, noises and clips
the gradient effect for data
points that are outliers.
That's how you guarantee
the differential privacy
of unique data points.
Who do you think is an
outlier in medical data?
Minorities? Yes.
So guess who gets noised and clipped?
Don't use differential
privacy in health data.
It's very scary I have to say.
All right, so what can we do?
Can we actually learn
under population shift
and if so, under which
kinds of population shift?
And so we look at four different kinds,
various correlations where
attribute and class are hot on
the diagonal, attribute imbalance
where you have more of a
specific kind of attribute
throughout all classes, class imbalance,
and then also attribute generalization
where we just don't observe
any specific attribute class pair
and we have to try to
generalize to that shift.
And we're in luck because actually many
of the default machine
learning data sets out there
exhibit these different kinds of shifts.
Class imbalance and attribute imbalance
have a lot of health data sets in them.
So this would be the
chest x-ray multi-site,
the MIMICNotes, the ChXpert dataset,
the MIMIC-CXR dataset.
But a lot of the other datasets
that we use in distributionally
robust optimization,
paper benchmarking also
exhibit spurious correlation
and attribute generalization effects.
And so what we find when
we benchmark the top papers
in this space on these different tasks is
that many of the algorithms
do indeed improve
on spurious correlation
and class imbalance.
But even really like great models
that perform extremely
well like DFR and CRT
in those two settings do not improve
and imbalance and attribute
generalization specifically.
This is an issue that we try
to decompose into, again,
this relative contribution
between representations
that can be trained and
classifiers that can be trained.
So if we freeze a representation
and try to improve a classifier,
we found that it's possible
that you can improve spurious correlations
and class imbalance.
If you improve the representation itself
you can have some small impact
to the attribute imbalance task,
but nothing improves
attribute generalization.
So this is a very difficult task
that is present in a lot
of healthcare settings
and it's something we need
to develop better models for.
A final thing to note
is almost every single
one of these papers, they
optimize for worst-group accuracy.
It's the gold standard for
subpopulation evaluation.
But do you remember what we've been going
through in many of these examples?
But the thing that we care more
about is, it's this like
false positive, right?
Like you don't want to
under diagnose people.
So worst-group accuracy is correlated
with things like adjusted accuracy,
but it's actually inversely proportional
to worst-group precision.
So when you are training your models
and evaluating them for subgroups,
be very careful which metrics you use
because it might actually
be significantly worse
for certain populations.
And so it's possible if
you're doing a triage task,
precision is actually what you care
about more than anything.
So how do we address some of these shifts?
Let's say that we have a
big source domain hospital
where we do really well and then we notice
that when we apply it to
a target domain hospital,
it actually has a drop in
performance that's too high.
We don't like that.
Wouldn't it be nice if
we could just attribute
these performance drops to specific shifts
in the distribution?
Because those are addressable, right?
So if we were able to decompose this,
we could say, you know,
"There's different parts of the source
and target distribution and
maybe I can collect more data
in the source or only have it apply
to specific populations in the target."
And so we actually have a
new paper where we do this.
We model shift attribution as a game.
You assume this is a
reasonably large assumption,
but you can do it in
some medical settings.
You have to assume that you
can specify a causal graph
that is reasonable for your setting.
And then you can model shift attribution
as a cooperative game where the players
are mechanisms of attribution,
each player contributes
to the target distribution
when it's in a coalition
and to a source distribution otherwise.
And the attribution mechanism is actually
the Shapley Value.
And so when we do this and
run it through a case study,
what we get is, let's say
that we have a algorithm
that's trained to predict
in hospital mortality
using vitals and labs from hospitals
in the American Midwest, large sample.
And then the model is
deployed in hospitals
in the American South smaller sample.
And we noticed that there is
an increase in the Brier score.
So it's more poorly calibrated
when we apply it to the target.
If we want to ask why the model fails,
we can come up with a causal graph using
the data features we have.
We can run our method, we
can say maybe it's going
to be easiest to focus on
the difference of distribution in age.
That's a mechanism of
shift I want to tackle.
We can look at the
difference between source
and target distributions of age
and say "Aha, what we can
do is collect more data
from older people on the source."
And we find that when we
do this, when we deploy
this specific targeted
data collection mechanism,
we have much better
performance at the target site
and it's better.
There is a lower distance between source
and target distribution
performance than if you
just did naive retraining with
the source and the target.
So the final thing I wanted to talk about,
which is maybe the most
outside of my wheelhouse
and maybe many of your wheelhouses given
that this is a machine
learning summer school,
is post-deployment considerations.
Because it's possible none of you really
will work on deployments,
but it's a thing I think
you should keep in mind
because even if you
don't deploy your model,
if your code is on GitHub, somebody might.
So let's think about
how we can ensure models
will augment and improve human healthcare.
So this is the transcript
from a crisis line call.
This is a reasonably common
thing that people volunteer
for in the United States
where for example,
you get some training saying you're
going to get texts like this.
I've added the highlighting
for self-reported race
and also for religious identity.
Normally this is all just black text
and that's what our participants got.
And we had people read through this
and we gave them some training.
We said, you know, "You have two options.
There's no liability risk
because this patient is going
to get help no matter what,
but if there's a risk of violence,
you should call the police, right?"
So just like in the outcome
definition part of the talk,
we have an if condition,
if there's a risk of violence
and a then condition,
then you should call the police, okay?
And then we ask people to
make this decision, right?
So they should always
call for medical help
unless there's this risk of violence
and then they should call the police.
And so at baseline people
just saw this and this task.
And then we have one
intervention we do where
we give them some advice and
we either give them advice
from a biased GPT model that
we intentionally biased.
It's easy to do so that it always says
"There's a risk of violence",
it always has Y equals one,
there's a risk of violence,
you should call the
police disproportionately
for black and Muslim subjects.
And then we had an unbiased model
where we fixed the probability.
So it did not disproportionately
say you should call
the police on black and
Muslim subjects, okay?
So treatment number one is
whether you as a volunteer
or if you're not in the control group,
that gets no advice, treatment
number one is whether you get
the biased or unbiased GPT
model giving you advice.
Treatment number two is
whether you get the descriptive
or the prescriptive part
of the training, right?
So remember we said if
there's no risk of violence,
you should call for medical help.
If and only if there's a risk of violence,
then you should call the police.
So in the y equals one case,
we could either give them the
descriptive recommendation,
RAI systems flag this
call for risk of violence,
or we could give them the then condition.
In this situation, our
model thinks you should call
for police or medical help, right?
And so this is the second treatment.
So there's two things that
are being randomized here.
If you're in the study group,
not the control group with no advice,
you're randomized to either get the biased
or unbiased GPT model and then
to either get the descriptive
or prescriptive recommendations, right?
And then you make the same
decision, you see the same text,
everything else is the same.
So just as a show of hands,
who thinks that the first treatment
is what's going to matter most?
Whether we gave you the
biased or unbiased GPT model.
Nobody thinks that.
Some people think that.
Who thinks that treatment number two,
whether we give you the if
or then condition is what's
going to matter most?
A lot of people think that.
So what we found is that
clinicians, actually
a really large group of
clinicians and non-clinicians
are not more likely to call the police
on black and Muslim subjects at baseline.
And that's important, right?
Like when they're given no advice,
it's they're not just proportionately
likely to call police on minorities.
However, when you give
them, as you all guessed,
the biased prescriptive recommendations,
clinicians and non-clinicians
are both much more likely
to call the police on black
and Muslim individuals.
But shockingly for me,
but not for you all who
are much more skeptical
and cynical than I am,
the descriptive flags
from the biased models
didn't have the same effect.
And this allowed the participants
to have retention of their
regional fair decision making.
The reason this is shocking to me is
because this is not part
of certainly my training,
but I would say globally are training.
If I tell you to predict a
label, it doesn't matter.
You've predicted Y is equal
to one, you don't think about,
well, when you deploy this,
make sure you have the if condition,
not the then condition or
the results will be wild.
Nobody tells you that.
And I don't think it's a very
commonly thought of issue in
deployments in machine learning
that when we are
optimizing for an outcome,
there's different ways in which the model
could give its advice.
And it doesn't matter if you
have exactly the same model,
tiny differences in how you present
that advice even to experts in this case,
will cause them to
follow incorrect prompts.
Yes?
Nothing we didn't even tell them it
was a GPT model.
We said we are training an
AI system to assist people
with triaging, right?
You are going to test this for us.
There will be some advice,
you should still follow your training.
Any other question? Clarification?
All right, so a final
thing that I want to go
through is I'm often asked by many people
whether we can just fix these
issues with explanations.
Actually I would say
maybe half of the papers
that I'm presenting here today,
what happened was I gave a presentation
and there was this one
person who was so obnoxious
and just said, "You
can fix that with this,
you can fix that with this."
And then I had this like
villain era rage year
where all my graduate
students just wrote papers
denying every claim this person made.
(laughing)
This is one of those papers.
So I like it a lot.
So if anybody ever asks you
can you fix your model bias
with explanations, the argument is,
well these models are very complex
and the complexity is part of the issue.
So can we use these
post-hoc explanation methods
in order to make them safer?
And this is particularly
a common justification
in health for example,
for designing a new explanation method.
Some of these methods
are extremely popular.
When I checked last LIME
had over 8,000 citations.
So it's a very common thing that happens.
You could do local or
global explanation methods,
but the issue here is that
what is an explanation method?
An explanation method is fundamentally
a local or global linear projection often
into a reduced space, right?
That's how you get
this explainability facet of the method.
And maybe that does make
it easier to interpret,
but the problem is like
all approximations,
there's going to be some
reduction in quality.
So our question is who has
the reduction in quality?
So we measured the fairness of local
and global explanation methods
and we're going to compare
the difference between
average fidelity across groups
and your worst case fidelity to
the original model performance
and then also the average
absolute difference
in fidelity across subgroups, right?
So if you have a model and
it performs in certain ways
and then you explain it,
how much worse is the
explanation for different people
than if you just would've
used the original model?
So we are not going to just
test this in the health MIMIC
setting of predicting ICU mortality,
which is usually what I do.
We also wanted to test this
across different human process
areas where AI has been
either proposed for
or is actively used for
assisting decision making.
So this would be in financial markets
for adult income prediction, for example,
to just determine whether you're
a credit worthy for a loan.
This would be for an educational
setting predicting whether
students pass specific exams.
And then in criminal justice
already there are models
that are allowed to predict
recidivism risk so that judges
could use it in bail
hearings to determine bail.
So these are all settings
where you could have an advice giving
AI that is deployed within the setting
and then the person making
the decision gets to use
that advice and maybe
there's an original model.
And then there's also
this explained version.
We find that the
explanation models, right?
So for both local and global explanations,
they induce subgroup fidelity gaps,
which should not be shocking, right?
Like who do you think
gets approximated into worse performance?
And we also find that this gap varies
with the dimension of data representation
in the explanation model.
That also makes sense.
The more you explain a model, right?
So like the lower dimensionality
you force it to be,
the worse the approximation errors get
and it disproportionately
affects subgroups often
that are underrepresented in your data.
A final thing that is maybe
more related to deployments
than the underlying technology
is people really trust things
when they're explained
in ways that are, again,
very surprising to me.
So humans, there are these
fantastic experiments
by Dr. Ayanna Howard of
formerly Georgia Tech,
I don't know if she's still there,
where she had a bunch of
students in a room like this
and then smoke started pouring
into the door and you know,
fire alarms went off and then there was
this cute little rescue robot
that they had previously seen
do a terrible job at navigation,
come into the room and say, you know,
"Follow me to safety."
And then people follow this robot past
the clearly marked exit that
looks safe towards a room
that looks like there is no exit
and the fire might
actually be coming from it.
Truly wild, so you know, this
has already been established
in robotic settings.
Roboticists that look at
human-computer interaction
have already established
that people can over-rely
on robotic systems
specifically in two settings
where they believe a robot
can perform a function
that it can't, right?
Or when the person expects
that the system mitigates risk,
it has some fail safe,
it's going to mitigate like crazy risks.
And those are both true
in health, I would argue.
Another thing that is really fun is
the fake group at Microsoft Research.
This is Hanna Wallach, Jenn
Wortman Vaughn and team,
they did this really fun
experiment where they took people
in New York where
housing prices, you know,
fluctuate quite a bit.
And so most New Yorkers are very aware
of like what a place would go for, right?
So they surveyed people about, you know,
what do you think this
this unit would go for?
And then they intentionally added,
and then they had a machine learning model
give its prediction of
what it would go for.
They had both a black-box model
and one that explained its prediction
by taking bedrooms times something
plus bathrooms times something,
and gave you a market prediction.
And they had some intentionally
misconfigured units.
So instead of a three bed,
one bath, it was a three bath,
one bed, which you would imagine
would not go for very much.
And so people predicted that at baseline.
When you gave them a
black-box model that predicted
that this three bathroom one bedroom
would go for a very high price, they said,
"Well the model is wrong obviously,
and we're not fooled by it."
But when you explained it with a formula,
well I just took this
times this, they said,
"Oh no, sounds good."
Then they took the higher market value.
And so, you know, we over trusts things
that we think we can see a mechanism for.
In general, it's a human thing.
It's not AI's fault, it's how we behave.
And the final thing is medicine
has a lot of black-boxes
that we use because we don't
know exactly how it works.
We do not know how acetaminophen works.
Think of about the next
time you take it actually.
We dunno how lithium works.
And I guarantee you most
doctors who prescribe an MRI
do not know exactly how
the MRI machine works.
We trust that there is a system
that vetted how these
things should be used.
We trust that there are audits
that the MRI machine is
serviced on a regular contract.
We trust a system of
regulation around it even
if we don't understand
exactly how a thing works.
And so if we need to trust
a system of regulation
around something, how do we get there?
And the analogy that I'm
going to make here is
to aviation where it used
to be very unsafe to fly.
I didn't know this,
but there's a aviation person
at MIT who was telling me
the history and I'm very
thankful I live now.
So aviation in the United
States has a lot of very formal
feedback loops in the federal government.
So lots of different agencies
work together to enhance
reporting, evaluation, and
auditing of different mechanisms.
There's a culture of safety.
So there's a federal agency that actually
has open safety investigations
where they assume
there's no blame assigned
until there's a full investigation.
And then they try to do
fair liability attribution
and there's a lot of training
and this is completely
absent in healthcare,
which is something that I
think is really frightening.
Pilots undergo really extensive training,
like thousands of hours in simulations.
So they know how to interact
with these automated systems
that give them prompts at different times.
We need to do the same thing in healthcare
so we can mitigate some
of these automation biases
with training that includes tools.
There's many ways you could think
about mapping this aviation model into
at least the American government.
The FDA on our side could mandate audits.
We have the FTC and
ARHQ that could monitor
what's happening within
different parts of deployments.
There could be ARPA-H that
provides open data banks
of representative groups.
So you can train and
audit your own models.
CMS could do regulation and accreditation.
You don't get reimbursed by the government
unless you've been
accredited for performing
at a certain rate and at least
hypothetically on our side,
HHS could do enforcement.
So if we find that your
models are underperforming
in a deployed setting,
then we're going to enforce
the legal code against you.
There are some problems,
hopefully I have convinced you,
that are unique to health
that we can't just map over.
And these are things that
are fundamentally inequities
and underlying data and processes
and we don't want them to
be learned and automated.
We were asked by a reviewer,
"What could those possibly be?"
So here are some examples.
Yeah, I, you know, everybody
has that reviewer too, right?
So as an example, "Gender concordance,
being the same gender as
your provider, increases
the patient's probability
of heart attack survival.
And this effect is driven
only by increased mortality
when male physicians
treat female patients."
That's not my favorite quote
from that paper actually.
That's in the proceedings
of the National Academy of Sciences.
My favorite quote is "When male clinicians
have more female
colleagues they train with,
they kill fewer female patients".
(laughing)
Which is like, are we like
that's a great dose response.
Does that mean you
should just be surrounded
by women more like I don't,
it's an interesting effect.
So this would be like if
male pilots crashed more
when they were flying
with female passengers,
which doesn't happen to my knowledge.
(laughing)
The second thing is we know that
Patient-physician-race-match
improves a lot of quality
of life outcomes and
just adherence outcomes.
And these are things
that are really important
to longer term safety and
knowledge about your condition.
So it'd be like if black
passengers only got
the in-flight safety announcement,
if there were a black pilot flying,
which I again, do not think
happens to my knowledge.
And the final thing is a
"Majority of Muslim women report
experiencing poor quality
care and maternity services
with indicated stereotypical
and discriminatory behavior."
As somebody with three kids.
I can say that this is true,
I've experienced it personally,
but also this would be like if
there were Muslim travel bans
and Muslim passengers were
always randomly screened.
This is true, I was randomly
screened on the way here
for the hundredth times.
So you know, there are lots of
things that happen in health
that you would not want to be replicated
in an aviation setting, right?
Once we have these sort
of regulatory bodies
that are involved.
There are no simple
fixes for AI in health.
As I said, this is going
to be an ongoing process
for diverse teams and data.
But if we consider sources
of bias in the data
when we select our problems
and collect our data.
If we evaluate models
comprehensively when we think
about outcome definitions
and develop our algorithms,
and if we recognize not
all gaps can be corrected,
but when you deploy a model,
it can still be useful
if you're careful about how
the model's advice is given,
then I think we can actually
work towards better outcomes.
This is work done by a really
fantastic group of students,
clinical and technical collaborators,
and really generous funding sources.
And I do think that if
we learn robust models,
audit diverse data,
and deploy fair advice,
we can create actionable insights
in human health, thank you.